Dude, my, both of the guys I took to open for me,
Craig and Mike were due. They took all the merchandise, packed all the merchant.
They didn't even pack it. They put it in. I said,
I'm getting a sprinter van for the weekend. Ah, cool.
And they usually pack up like three suitcases of merch and stuff.
It all in there. And instead they didn't,
they just took the boxes of Merck and put it in the van on the way to Riverside.
And we got out of the car and I was like, what the?
And there were like eight boxes of merge. And I was like, what is all this?
And they were like, Oh, we'll just go, we'll leave it in the van.
And I was like, what? And they were like, well,
we're just going to put it in a van. Right. And I was like, no,
what are you talking about? And he said, we're not, well,
this van isn't with us for the weekend. And I said, no, it's not dude.
Now let me explain why that's stupid. Now, everybody, if you're like me,
your blood's boiling. Right, right. Even just reminiscing about it. Okay.
Now I want you to just take a step back. Right? I want you to just relax.
I want you to take that blood. I want you to dial it down a notch.
I want you to, I want you to turn down the heat.
I want it to go from medium to light medium. I want it to just,
I want you to take the oven and I want you to just turn it down. Okay.
Now why does that make us mad now? I'll tell you why it makes us mad. Okay.
Here's why getting a,
getting a car to take you from, from LA to Riverside. It's about 300 bucks.
Okay. Getting your car to, uh,
to take it from Riverside to San Diego spot. 300 bucks. Okay.
Get in your car from San Diego back to LA. It's about 500 bucks. Okay.
So that's all expense. Fine. It doesn't matter. Sure. I, you know,
I need to get their bags bags. I understand, but need to bring it back.
Okay. So that's about a thousand dollars,
whatever you want to call a little bit more than a thousand dollars. Okay. Now,
if I rent the driver all weekend. Yeah, sure.
No dents, but that's going to be five grand. Okay.
Now that's well, it's actually going to be more than five grand.
It's going to be seven, eight, nine grand. Now would I do that? Sure. No dense,
but what I do that, no, because it just makes no
sense to anyone. Who's not a caveman. All right. Or a four-year-old.
Okay. So there we go. Now that's where the blood's Ryzen. Okay.
Now of course I told you the dog. Now I understand if you're, if you're like me,
you're listening to me. And if you're a longtime fan of John,
that I understand your blood is boiling because you like me, you get it.
We're part of the art. When you're a cult, your blood boils together.
So our blood is boiling. It's boiling, it's pot.
It's piping hot dude. And I'm mad. Now,
let me tell you why, why it's real hard to keep the blood from,
really bursting out of my eyeballs. Okay.
Mike's been open in me with me for six years.
We have done hundreds and hundreds of
cities
and we haven't never one time
ever done it that way.
Okay. So those of you still with us,
those of you who didn't pass on yet because of the blood coming out of your eyes
and ears. Okay. Because I'm Zen right now. I'm just chilling.
Uh, He says, well.
Now we got to take all the boxes with us to the hotel and then back to San Diego
and then back to the thing.
And then we've got to put it in the box and the V and I say, you know,
when you get so mad that you're just kinda like, yeah,
there's nothing he can do. And okay, cool. So we'll just chill and I'll be mad,
right? I say, that's cool, man.
I'm not carrying a box.
So now he has to deal with it because he, this is my impression of him.
And then Craig too, was like, Oh, that's when I thought I found that.
Then we were tanking. Oh yeah,
you got 19 grand to just
dude. Oh, no
quick farts broke. Yeah.
You knew, dude. Do some mental, do some thought, man,
do thought, Hey man, do thought,
thought,
do it not do that beyond the first
thought, take it there.
How could you be such a ignoramus? Now if Mike were here, he would say,
ignoramus. I never heard that word. Thought,
take it past that
guys. Getting all, carrying boxes. And I'm sitting around like, I'm a, like,
I'm a laughing. Like I'm that guy.
Look at them. Carry the boxes. It's their own fault.
There's nothing they can do. Dude.
If I play a character in a real serious drama and I'm like,
you think I won't win an Oscar, dude. you. You think I won't win an Oscar?
I want a Oscar
[inaudible] and everybody on set when I'm doing, I'll be like,
I dunno if that's the move and then it comes out, bro. That's it
like raps. My neck hurts my lipstick. My lower back hurts. It's all good.
One of the vans we took back from, uh,
San Diego, bro. No, look, I don't know if I got an iron deficiency or what,
let me be real with your babies. When I go to a hotel room,
I keep that. 76,
75 might as well be an ice box for me.
I'll keep that. 76. I go in and the air is always blaring.
First thing daddy does is turn that off. I let the,
I let the mechanism rest for about five minutes.
And then that it turns that heat up bro. 76,
At least. Do you understand me? Okay.
Now my opener Mike is a fat.
All right. Now we know about fat. Dude, they get what?
Say it together. If you're in your car, you're in your cubicle.
Everyone said together, they get what? Sweaty.
Okay? Their hands are all clammy and they're, you know what I mean?
It's all sweat. It's got all sweaty, sweat.
They sweat on there where everyone it together, forehead,
everyone stayed together. sweat. Where I wanna say together under their,
under their nose in their lap. I remember when you were, remember that one kid,
when you were in, uh, like fourth grade that got the sweat above his lip.
What the was wrong with that kid, bro? I could sweat.
I could be in the Sahara desert with a parka on and snow
pants and straight up a ski hat.
And if I would never get the beads of sweat above my lip, dude,
that kids was always so that kid. I would stare at that kid, man,
when he would talk and be like, why are there beads of sweat above his lip.
The sweats on their lip, bro. Grow up, hurry up.
Grow up and grow mustache. Hide it. Do it.
I'd rather see someone with a wet stash than a beat it up or lip
IL dude, bro.
Anyway, he's like, Oh, it's so hot.
So we turn on the air fine. Now, you know like with cars,
I literally, if you can get your D your,
your temperature perfect in your car,
I straight up don't believe you it's either too cold or too hot.
That's how cars go because you're in too close proximity to the air
conditioners or the heater. All right. You cramped up.
You're basically in a little thing, you know,
you're like getting this movable large embryo
anyway. Uh, so,
So I went, so it was cold. And then, uh,
so it was cold. And then, and I was like, it's too hot or it's too cold.
So I put the on. And dude, when I turned the air off,
The thing still counts. What degrees it is.
So I turned the air off and it quickly ripped up to 82 degrees. Now, guess what?
I am happy and I'm serious and I'm not sweating. I'm chilling.
Do I have an iron deficiency? Mayb. I fall asleep for a little bit.
Now. Sometimes Mike will sneak to Aaron, but that's when I get ripped warn Matt.
Okay. So he didn't do it this time. I wake up bro. He's naked.
He took off all his clothes except for his Spanx underwear.
And I look over and I'm like, this really has underwear on.
And it made me happy because that's how you do it. You don't around dude.
You don't change the air conditioning for the guy who's paying for the van.
By the way, Craig was on my side. He was like, I like it hot
anyway, you can't get your air right in the car. What was the deal with that?
Everyone's all excited about Tesla, Prius and all that, bro. Get the air.
Right man. That's when I'll be happy.
Um.
So I'm trying to.
And I'm cool with my sexuality man, naked dudes in my vans. I don't give a, man.
Dick flopping around don't care. Uh,
Oh man, this made me laugh.
We were in San Diego and
we went to go get a lunch. Me and the three.
I mean the two of us Craig and Mike, we sit down, we're at a bar,
it's got like a bit of a bar menu, find whatever. Okay. I get the Turkey wrap.
It's got a wheat wrap and your boy's trying to keep it healthy. Okay.
It's fine.
Mike goes like this, I'll get the,
uh, the Frank sandwich.
And I say, Oh cool. In my head. And he says, and she says,
okay, writes it down on her pad. And then she, and then Mike says,
is that a cheeseburger? And she says,
yeah, now
we all know. It's not, we all know it's hotdogs
because nobody would ever describe a food as a Frank when it's not a
hot dog. Right. If I was eating a cheeseburger and I said, Hey man,
this ballpark beef, Frank sure is good. You'd say quick,
get that guy to the hospital.
Cause he doesn't know what words are.
All right. So
by the way, what the waitress did was correct.
He said, that's a cheeseburger. Right? And she said, yeah,
because you wouldn't want to make a guy.
Who's obviously lost his mind or broken
his brain upset.
You just agree with crazy people.
It's like when a guy on meth is on the sidewalk and says, you know,
Jesus is coming right. You just say, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So he said, I'll have the Franks. And she said,
great. And he said,
that's a cheeseburger. Right?
And in her head,
this was a crazy guy on meth with his pants around his ankles
saying, you know, Jesus is come right. And that's what I thought too.
I thought, Oh, how sad Mike's brain broke.
Keep it a pay. She said, yes. I wanted to shake her hand.
But I didn't make a big deal.
Now cut to obviously way too long later
because it's a bar and bar food always takes too long.
She puts down two big,
messy hotdogs.
And I look at Mike's face and it's not good.
Not because he's a six,
but because his face did something like what the she leaves? And he says,
Oh, I didn't want this. And I said, huh.
And he says, I thought it was a cheeseburger.
And I said, huh. And he said,
did you see me ask if it was a cheeseburger? And I say, yeah.
And then she said, yes, it was a cheeseburger. And I said course.
And he said, but it's hot and talks. And I said, yeah.
Cars.
And he said, why did you say it was a cheeseburger? And I said,
because your brain's broken.
You order Franks.
You order some ballpark racks.
You asked if it was a cheeseburger. She said yes,
because she didn't want to deal with you taking your Dick out or some and all
over the table. Cause y'all obviously crazy pers
Hey dude, I'll get the ballpark. But Hey dude,
I'll get the ballpark beef Franks. Okay. Is that a salad?
Yes. Great. Here you go.
Oh, what the? This isn't a salad. No, you.
It says Frank's your 36.
He ate it. He ate the whole thing.
You know why fat slob.
That's why that's also why it's too hot in the sprinter van.
You know, it's all your fault, man. Nothing on this. Nothing on this one.
I guess it's my fault. It's never been my fault. I've never, ever,
I've never had my fault.
Anyway.